[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a une liste qu'on a voulu très
équilibré dans chaque quartier on a le
même nombre de candidats nous avons des
gens de de grande qualité je trouve de
compétences d'analysé d'expérience de
formation une liste rajeunie par rapport
à celle du mandat précédent puisque la
moyenne d'âge est de moins de 45 ans en
même temps une liste d'expérience
puisque un tiers de personnes qui la
composent ont déjà eu une expérience
d'élu municipal un thème fort et reste
le même que commanda précédent
c'est-à-dire tout ce qui concerne en
priorité la jeunesse et on va de la
crèche une nouvelle crèche et crèche
collective qui permet une éducation
forte
on va passer par l'école où là on va
aussi augmenter notre capacité à aider
les jeunes dans leur scolarité et on
continue de façon très logique avec les
plus âgés sur l'aide à la formation sur
l'aide à l'emploi que ce soit avec
l'emploi d'un agent fait pour ça ou la
création de ce qu'on appelle une régie
de quartier
[Applaudissements]
une de mes premières décisions va être
de faire revoter la création d'un
médecin d'une un poste de médecin
municipal ça devient une urgence se
plissent vient de se passer dans ce
confinement dans ce que cette endémie
nous montre à quel point ces déserts
médicaux on ne peut ne peuvent pas
perdurer que ce soit dans les hôpitaux
mais que ce soit aussi dans la médecine
de ville
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]